like many nations the united kingdom has
been hit hard by kovid 19 there is the
tragic loss of life about a hundred
thousand people
at last count there's also the economic
devastation which is
actually worse than here in the united
states or in many other developed
nations
the biggest slowdown in more than three
centuries
holly williams has the story from london
good morning the uk government says this
country is facing its worst recession
since the great frost of 1709
back when the american colonies were
still british
and benjamin franklin was just three
years old
they've been trading at borough market
for at least
800 years it's still open but now
on most days it's close to deserted
almost crippling really we've had to be
really careful and a bit invented to
survive charlie foster's family has been
selling fruit and vegetables in london
for four
generations employing more than 50
people
but they've had to furlough half of them
are you confident that you can survive
another year of this another year
no we wouldn't be able to survive that
long you'd go under you'd go bankrupt
for sure yeah
while the u.s economy shrank by three
and a half percent last year
the uk economy contracted by nearly 10
and economists say it'll take longer to
recover
this food bank is in a wealthy part of
central london
a stone's throw from fashionable
boutiques and houses that sell for tens
of millions of dollars
many of the people receiving food here
used to be
middle class i never thought in my
wildest dreams i ever come down here
having to be coming to a food bank i
used to give people money on the streets
jane austen was a chef working in
upscale venues before the pandemic hit
now she told us she has to choose
between heating her apartment
or buying food i felt embarrassed to be
quite honest i felt
it was one of my lowest points like to
come and ask for
food and ironically this food bank is in
one of the wealthiest areas of london
it's it's ironic it's absolutely
horrendous i've paid taxes
and this is what i'm getting for my
taxes it's just
heartache and pain it's breathtaking
dr miata fanbula is an economist who
told us the british government's slow
response to the pandemic
along with brexit have created a perfect
storm of economic pain
you have families that literally cannot
feed their children and i think as we
see more images of this
there will be a sense that you know our
government are letting people down and
it is unacceptable you're saying this
could bring down the government i think
it's going to become a really thorny
political issue for them
for the first time ever last year unicef
the united nations agency that gives
humanitarian assistance to children
helped feed british children one
prominent member of the uk government
called it a quote
political stunt for cbs this morning
saturday
holly williams in london sounds like
it's a necessary one though thank you
holly